hasta ahorita hemos hablado de resistor
es capacitores y algunos otros
componentes los hemos conectado y hemos
aprendido acerca de la ley de ohm para
resistor es y también hemos aprendido
algunas cosas acerca de resistor es en
serie ahora vamos a ver las leyes de
kirchhoff que bueno básicamente son
leyes de sentido común que podemos
derivar observando circuitos simples en
este vídeo vamos a ver la ley de kurtzio
de la corriente aunque también es
conocida como la primera ley de kickoff
o como la ley de nodos pero bueno
empezamos por aquí tenemos dos resistor
es en serie y aquí lo que tenemos es un
nodo esto es un nodo digamos que a estos
resistor es en serie le ponemos una
corriente y bueno la corriente
simplemente descarga fluyendo y sabemos
que la carga no se acumula en ningún
lugar y por eso sabemos que esta
corriente pasa por el resistor y sale
del otro lado luego también fluye a
través del nodo hasta acá
fluye a través de este otro resistor y
sale de este lado toda la corriente que
entra por aquí sale por acá eso es algo
que definitivamente sabemos es el
principio de conservación de la carga
que nos dice que la carga no se acumula
en ningún punto a esta corriente le
vamos a llamar y uno ya está corriente
le vamos a llamar y dos y aquí como
están las cosas sabemos que podemos
escribir inmediatamente que y uno es
igual a dos esto se reduce directamente
de lo que estábamos diciendo de que la
carga no se acumula en ningún punto
ahora supongamos que tenemos otro
resistor por aquí que a este nodo
tenemos conectado otro resistor entonces
alguna parte de esta corriente se va a
ir por acá
llamémosle a esa corriente
3 y entonces esto de aquí ya no es
necesariamente cierto ya no podemos
asegurar que uno es igual a dos ahora lo
que sí sabemos es que toda la corriente
que entra a este nodo tiene que salir lo
que sí podemos decir es que uno es igual
a dos
y 3 y bueno en general lo que sí podemos
decir es que toda la corriente que entra
es igual a la corriente que sale y
básicamente esta es la ley de kirch of
si lo queremos decir con una anotación
un poco más matemática podemos poner por
aquí el símbolo de suma y sumamos aquí
todas las corrientes que entran y eso
tiene que ser igual a la suma de todas
las corrientes que salen esta es una
forma de expresar la ley de kitshoff
bueno y ahora lo que quiero hacer es
generalizar esto un poco más digamos que
tenemos aquí un nodo y algunos cables
que llegan a este novo y en cada uno de
estos cables hay corriente fluyendo voy
a poner todas las flechas apuntando
hacia el novo se ve un poco extraño pero
vas a ver que tiene sentido todas las
corrientes están fluyendo hacia el nodo
en este caso cuando todas las corrientes
fluyen hacia el nuevo la ley de kickoff
nos dice que la suma de todas las
corrientes tiene que ser igual a cero la
suma de todas las corrientes tiene que
ser igual a cero si yo sé que se ve un
poquito extraño pero veamos cómo
funciona digamos que esta corriente es
de un camper digamos que esta otra
corriente también es de un amper
amper y la pregunta aquí es esta
corriente cuánto es si utilizamos la ley
de kirchhoff escrita de esta forma aquí
lo que tenemos es que una vez más una
pero más otro amper más la corriente que
nos interesa y tiene que ser igual a
cero y lo que esto significa es que y
tiene que ser igual a menos tres y bueno
en general si tenemos menos tres amperes
fluyendo hacia el nodo eso lo que
significa es que tenemos tres amperes
saliendo del nodo aquí tenemos una pero
entrando al novo otro amper entrando al
nodo otro amper entrando al nodo
3 samper saliendo del nuevo y bueno otra
forma de ver esto esto por cierto son
tres formas distintas de ver exactamente
lo mismo pero bueno si tenemos aquí un
nodo y un montón de cables unidos a este
novo pero esta vez voy a definir que
todas las corrientes están fluyendo
hacia afuera del nodo y aquí sucede
exactamente lo mismo la suma de todas
las corrientes tiene que ser igual a
cero claro que aquí todas las corrientes
estaban entrando al nodo entonces vamos
a ponerle una e por aquí de entrar y
aquí todas las corrientes están saliendo
del nodo entonces le vamos a poner una s
de salida y podemos hacer el mismo
ejercicio aquí también si decimos que
estas cuatro corrientes son de un amper
y nos preguntamos cuál es la corriente
de aquí
bueno pues tenemos que la suma de todas
las corrientes tiene que ser igual a
cero así es que tenemos que 1
más uno más uno más uno que son todas
estas corrientes que sí conocemos más
esta corriente que queremos saber cuánto
vale la suma de todas estas corrientes
pensando como que todas están saliendo
del nodo tiene que ser igual a cero
entonces esta última corriente tiene que
ser igual a menos 4 para que la suma en
efecto sea igual a cero entonces esta
corriente de aquí tiene que ser igual a
menos 4 amperes amperes y bueno esa es
la idea de la ley de corrientes de
kirchhoff la razonamos a partir de
principios básicos porque toda la carga
que entra tiene que salir por alguna de
las rutas posibles y así es como
llegamos a esta expresión de aquí que es
la ley de corrientes de kirch joe y
bueno llegamos a una fórmula un poco más
simple si definimos que todas las
corrientes fluyen hacia el nodo si
definimos que todas las corrientes están
entrando al novo aunque algunas de ellas
en ser negativas pero bueno esta es otra
forma de escribir la ley de corrientes
de kirchhoff y bueno por supuesto que se
puede definir lo mismo pero ahora con
las corrientes saliendo del nodo y
obtenemos esta otra forma de escribir la
ley de corrientes de kitshoff aunque
aquí también vamos a tener algunas
corrientes negativas en cualquier
momento puedes utilizar cualquiera de
las tres formas de la ley de corrientes
de kirchhoff y las vamos a usar un
montón cuando estamos haciendo análisis
de circuitos